[Music]
it was very agricultural community it
was mostly just cattle and farmland
[Music]
you had this small little town of
Watford and then all of a sudden all of
these people move in
this is crude oil here and so they need
to actually physically pump it out of
the ground if you would have well well
well well well well well well well well
well
[Music]
in 2016 we at the 1 billion barrel mark
of produced oil
the thing that made North Dakota
extremely vulnerable was the influx of
men with a lot of money of course of
course you know just like all the oil
field workers came Flint you know find
out for the boom right along with it
came the drugs and the sex and the guns
they work twelve sixteen hours a day you
know it's hard work oil work is not easy
work and so they want to relieve their
stress and how do they relieve their
stress these men need that outlet these
men need that comfort these men need sex
people have been murdered up here people
have been raped there massive drug
issues up here you have a boom you have
everything else that comes along with
money
[Music]
my name is windy lysenko and I am the
founder for her North Dakota I'm a
victim advocate for those experienced
exploitation and trafficking when I
first arrived to North Dakota I had no
idea what I was walking into the ratio
of men to women when I got here it was a
hundred to one so there was a hundred
men to every one woman I've had it
happened a couple times but I can
remember specifically the first time it
happened I went to Walmart just to get
some makeup or something and I was
dressed in a turtleneck and boots and I
was shocked because these two guys came
up to me in the makeup department and
said hey do you work the back roads and
I was just I'm a city girl you know so
I'm like the back roads and then I was
like oh my gosh he's he's propositioning
me obviously I think that at that time
if you were a woman in Williston not
married not visibly with another guy
they automatically assumed you were here
to work in prostitution because that was
really the only two people groups were
the local women and then those working
as strippers or in prostitution
damn it that way though episode them
that way this time huh
we'll do a man's bet the other one gets
to call the other one a man it's not a
woman I would say that if you don't make
$100,000 a year as a minimum there's an
issue
you're an idiot in the oil mr. Jacques
together the best of the best people all
of my oh my god so the bus there's no
question about it and then I started up
Magnus a little over two and a half
years ago so I invented a couple of
products introduced a couple of products
to the oil field and I got lucky
to be honest with you I just got lucky
[Laughter]
like 10 months old
this is my daughter she's got her pets
she loves her little chickens you know
this is what we did mate oh don't get me
wrong there's a lot of challenges in us
because there's not a lot of services
for the family
I have no bowling alley grocery there's
only really there's two grocery stores
but there's really one big grocery store
you got to drive forever to go see a
good doctor so we do that we do this
barbecue just really cool things you
know is how you handle the stress yeah
yeah how this stress is really high I
mean for this job yeah because if I
don't perform somebody else is gonna
come in and take over the work then I
lose all that profit and then I gotta go
find it
start again sorry I feel stressful that
it got his keep after
[Music]
every squad has a ar-15 and then a
usually has a shotgun as well usually
what we have in here so we have our
camera system up front right here and
then our monitor this is our radar so we
can monitor vehicle speeds our computers
we receive a lot of it very varied a lot
of everything you could have toxicated
drivers to domestic defaults then no two
days are the same you know you go from
helping a little lady out of medical to
arresting a guy on a possession with
intent to deliver narcotic case you know
five minutes later to unlocking
somebody's vehicle it really varies
10:39 gonna be 300 block 8th Street
southeast North Dakota 1 9 0 Adam
Charles Victor hi ma'am
hey certain gents in the police
department reading I'm stopping his you
don't have a front license plate on the
vehicle
no we hit a deer okay you gotta get the
mountain gotta get on there
sounds good Casey oh there is a gun
where's it at okay do me a favor hypo
for me where is it where's it up he's
gonna be stand right back there for me
it's just right there there's the
insurance in there okay yep there's no
magazine in it I appreciate it
dispatch 1104 firearm ninety-nine
there's a lot of money with the oil and
with that comes a lot of a lot of people
from all over the country and all over
then all over the world to be honest
with you and we do have a large large
issue with narcotics and alcohol abuse
tell me about this connection between
world prices and the numbers of calls it
seems very clear we look at the prices
when they were 42 years ago for a barrel
of West Texas oil now it's over a
seventy about 74 today and we see that
people are drawn to our area to support
the oil industry people who are very
busy and want to relax and I do
I mean when I'm busy I like to relax
also but then they'll gentleman will
drink too much sometimes and then the
drug community comes in and gets
methamphetamine and cocaine and other
things and that cycle was drinking in
the drugs when the people who are used
to being busy all the time and they
don't have enough time nothing's to do
in their own time the problems happen
[Music]
I just like mostly pretend like it
didn't happen like you know what I mean
and it's to the point where I'm really
starting to forget so it's hard to like
delve back into it you Mike about it
again you know I mean cuz I've been
working so hard to forget that part of
my life
[Music]
hi are you pretty how are you eyeliner I
see money there here I know I can't
believe I've I think it was gonna happen
that's why I'm gonna be like mom right
now but have fun be 23 but be
responsible you're working so hard I got
to yeah I had an ex-boyfriend and he
worked on the oil fields and stuff he
was working really long hours and so to
deal with working those long hours he
started doing drugs specifically crystal
meth in order to stay awake and you know
continue doing his job and stuff after
he lost his job and we broke up and
stuff like handed up like
selling me to his boss for like a half
an hour and he took the money and left
and I was like all by myself in order to
go had nothing I just had to do what I
had to do to survive you know if you
have the choice of sleeping out in the
cold or doing what you got to do what
are you gonna do in the middle of all
that that's how I ended up getting
connected as a pimp one of her very
first buyers was actually a pimp a very
prominent pimp in the area that was
sending a clear message to her that she
couldn't work independent or the way
that she was working and that she needed
to be under his control and that scared
her you have an idea where this being
are right now I know it was I don't want
to talk about him oh I just I feel like
I don't I don't wanna get shot or
anything do you feel me like I just
don't want to talk about the pimp when I
saw her before she was just this like
fresh 19 year old bubbly um this time
that was gone I mean the the life had
definitely bit her just people men the
post office guy I mean just anybody
doctors teachers these men that are
going out and buying sex these are all
people and nobody knows because it's
such a big secret and without these guys
these buyers that this wouldn't be
happening without their greed and their
piggish selfish desires none of this
would happen
[Music]
[Applause]
got that stuff to go got a box charge
I'll go with the vests and stuff
Oh char just think either I touched it
anything we're looking for anything the
vehicle we're looking for any trace of
Olivia that we can find this is a very
sociable likes to joke around hang out
with people likes the Gulf spend time
with their kids spend time with her
friends yeah I mean she's any normal 32
year old you
[Music]
well I was 11 when I started running
away from him and it wasn't out of an
act of rebellion it was I had
experienced early sexual child abuse by
the father figure in my home I'm at 13
years old I was at school um one day and
there had been a girl that had I'd gone
to school with who was a little bit
older who everybody knew she had an
older boyfriend and she started talking
about her boyfriend and how he's just
this nice guy and he spoils her and she
can get anything she wants from him and
he was having a party that night and she
said yeah it's gonna be a lot of older
people and but my boyfriend is really
cool you'll have a good time and the
night was going on and it definitely was
older people at 13 I would have to say
they were probably 30s and 40s she came
up to me and she said hey you need to go
in the bedroom and I was like why what's
up and I just figured it was because
they were fighting or whatever and and
she was still with him and she kept
going like go you know get in the room
and I thought okay and then I saw the
man hand her boyfriend money so I went
in to the room and set on the edge of
the bed and it was darkly lit and
within less than a minute the couple
walked in the room it's almost like a
dream it's almost like a fog and all I
could hear was like his voice
instructing his purse lady on what to do
and I heard on kiss her and by the time
she started touching me
I had disassociated and so they had such
latina things I couldn't understand why
[Music]
my need for love was always associated
with sex
and so I just remember in that moment
kind of happening of it attitude I was
like um yeah I was just like well there
goes my search for what's good in the
world I guess there's none you know and
I would have to say that's when my
personality changed from being innocent
to keeping in I guess you know like well
if I'm gonna if I'm that person I might
as well be that person and I was 13
I remember this from last year this rule
in a particular road but once you saw
getting into anything south of here that
was all brand new to me go up go up ah
20 mm REIT I got down in the water and
then I went a little bit north I was
kind of just going with the wind though
you know when she disappeared the truck
disappeared as well we cannot find the
truck you running license plates all
that type of thing you'd think that
someone would have had eyes on this
truck by now you know so that's
suspicious in itself we you can't really
see it from you know looking straight at
it so when we flew over the top of it
that's when you can see all that stuff
and you know there's things down there
cooler and we don't know how long that
and that Harvey's been sitting down
there so you know get out there and
the bottles laying all over the place
this doesn't look too old hey Jerry
anything interesting in there
Val used to be fine thought foolish
people are we could figure out when this
fell you know I mean yeah just a come on
I'm going
[Music]
there's a truck over here too Ranger it
looks like it's been here for a while
it almost looks a two-tone
I'm gonna drop up in here that was just
an abandoned truck it wasn't be the one
that we're looking for but when when
we're out there looking you come across
that quite a bit and it's it's good to
go double check maybe you know there's
someone else out there it could it may
maybe not be necessarily Olivia it could
be someone else out there I'm on the
Bakken started kicking you started
seeing fatalities in the road people
getting run off the road people getting
sideswiped by semis you know and then
you got a look at the all the hard drugs
that came with the Bakken you know
there's so many different things that
are available here now that weren't
available when I was growing up here I
felt safe I could ride around new town
and know that I was okay now I wouldn't
even let my 14 year old son run around
the town because I don't know who's here
there's drugs people who are trying to
get these kids addicted to drugs are
gonna look for the younger ones here try
this
take this smoke this I wanted him to
know this can have this can happen to a
full-grown woman who happened to go
alone in a town that I was safe in when
I was younger this could happen to
anybody
that's exactly why like dogs have been
seen as a great source of support and
comfort and a lot of trauma survivors
and those who struggle with
post-traumatic stress are actually given
prescriptions for dogs how did you guys
meet up she was in the bartender okay oh
he would come with his work crew I knew
his work crew and I knew him because he
was this is a real little drunk man when
I he was so drunk I was trying to sober
him up yeah you would usually you
usually crack open a beer on the way on
the way home from work and uh when you
get up what do you wherever you live if
you live in Makkah where you just start
drinking and then a lot of times we have
to take a cab or one of the guys would
have a trust there and we would all
Drive and they would just throw wads of
cash oh that felt good
it's not like they were receiving
anything from the girl they didn't even
find her attractive you know there was
nothing but they had this wad of cash
and they just wanted to throw it
everybody was trying to get the same
girl thank first picture we ever took
together
I was his bartender when I first knew
him I was super I was really addicted to
drugs at that time I was in a really
dark point in my life I worked hard to
get my drugs
go home do my drugs get ready go to work
go home to my it was just a baby work
cycle I'm reducing
what I remember what do you look at me
because I got to the point where I felt
so stuck and stranded that I did place
an ad on Backpage and I wouldn't I
wouldn't I didn't post my picture
because I was so no one between
Williston Hyuga but I felt like that was
my only way as if I could come up a big
chunk of cash really fast and I guess
maybe like there was that little voice
inside my head that just said don't
don't go through with it and I got
emails and I just I never went through
with it but I just never forget having
been placing that ad when that was like
how I got to this point
mm-hmm and I was after that that I just
started working harder at regular jobs I
crawled out of the belly of most and I
was I was I don't think I would have
made it on another year if I hadn't met
Josh and and that's what empowerment
feels like you you are an empowerment
like I'm sorry it's mushy but doesn't
she see me
I almost prayed that I would know about
and this is really emotional
[Music]
[Applause]
it all depends on the price of oil
what's your best price I think right now
we're about the best yep 75 ish dollars
right in there it's everybody's busy I
can get all my guys trained and safety
and and all of that stuff in right here
so holds tight yeah
we supply the water to the frack we
supply the water to them and then they
uh they'll distribute the water on the
frack whoever they need to go so our
jobs like when we go say that we're
doing like day shift night shifts we're
making sure that the frack has enough
water to like keep going throughout the
entire day and yeah you definitely do
make a hell of a lot more money well
you've been just like regular things
like you can go push shopping carts of
the grunt at the at the like the store
and make like 14 bucks an hour
I like back home that day like you'd
only make like seven
that people are there just to work and
they work very hard and do a good job
but then they have a lot of money to
spend on alcohol drugs prostitutes all
the problematic things that draw crime
to our areas
I'm so I'm gonna pretend I'm a man
interested in a woman John for sex there
you go
sorry this username is taken John
Francis John for sex 69 I don't know you
could buy a person as easily as you
ordered a pizza I'm logged in under
Williston North Dakota and there's nude
modeling um you can't see it's just
absolutely disgusting see these girls
these girls are this one right here um
Chaz 105 she's 21 years old she's in
Williston North Dakota and her eyes are
just empty you know she's been doing
this for a long time
you can tell sometimes they literally
have guns to their head like they
they're um in this picture she's not
doing it willingly she has to in order
to meet her quota and get her dates and
bring in the money she has to hustle and
that's one of the things that I look for
when I'm looking at the girls pictures I
look for identifiable tattoos do the
tattoos indicate that she is someone's
property or the neck is very very common
the neck across the chest anywhere
really but those those indicate property
of the the trafficker wants that girl to
never be able to cover that up without
thinking you know or never be able to
wear clothing that would disguise the
fact that she belongs to him I was
branded on my back and it's covered over
it it was under here and it was a
property of tattoo what was the name of
the game KK you saw the record
okay off the record off the record so
that was that was my experience all
before the age of 16
there was a man but paid very very close
attention to me and it was like no other
guys talked to me you know now that I
look back on it and he was definitely
giving off of this this vibe like I
belonged to him and again going through
the healing process now I know that that
was probably the first time I had ever
experienced feeling like I had a dad
he's like well you know I have these
friends they've got a couple kids and
you could stay with them you'll probably
have to do some housekeeping watch their
kids form but hey it's better than
jumping couches you know it was normal
it was like a normal home you know they
had people in and out all the time and
they had kids running around and I would
help the wife cook and just hang out and
I felt really super comfortable and then
I remember his wife saying to me he
wants you tonight
and he wants me tonight what I could you
know like what you got you guys are my
family like please don't do this
I remember going please don't do this he
wound up having sex with me that night
and it became a regular to pain and that
was part of my duty to earn my keep to
keep my house to stay welcome in the
clubhouse to go on rides it was my first
time riding on a Harley it was just like
a dream and in exchange to be living
that dream sex was exchanged one night I
went to a get-together with those same
group of people and the husband that I
had been having sex with took me over to
the original guy that welcomed me into
the party and he said she's ready for
you
so he had sex with me that night I was
getting dressed and before I could even
get dressed he grabbed me by the arm and
he took me down the hallway and he threw
me in another room and and he told the
guy in there he said it she's yours now
and so I became what was known as
property of that group of people how are
you you having a good day
stop bike riding how are you what you
gotta be better than okay come on that's
alright you have a good day okay have
fun
bye
the good thing about the boom the boom
has brought a lot of good things to the
community it's brought a new event
center the Roughrider center a new high
school a new hospital a lot of new
businesses it's it's brought a lot of
good people into this town dispatch
level four
holy cow no no I'm talking about the
glass all over for my favorite stuff
okay
so holy cow he literally did do it you
heard the word I mean he did act like he
was gonna hit me and do that you know
thing and kind of smoke my body says but
I hate you guys so let me look at your
Facebook quick chat a turd once more hey
that's what I can see you take your loss
I can see and the kids weren't here
right
no they won't thank goodness I know well
we're not together anymore
probably having getting along okay and
the kids are yours right Arizona what's
yours
he hates me you know have you been
drinking yes how much has he been
drinking
we looked at the numbers if you got rid
of alcohol and narcotics in our
community you'd see our crime rate
dropped to almost drop at least 80% most
domestic violence calls we go to are
either alcohol or narcotic related
I I do have a weapon and it's a nice
little dagger knife that slips right
into the portion of my jeans and I can
just whip it out and you know instead of
punching somebody I can stab them I've
never had to use it but it makes me feel
more confident
so right now we're going to one of the
larger bars here they have dancing it's
right across the street from the
infamous Vegas hotel this hotel has been
a place known for prostitution
long before the boom you know and then
when the boom came it just it exploded
[Music]
okay so there are some pimps right there
you can see them right there right there
to the right at the very end of the wall
how do you actually like no he's a
beautiful he's been in town for a long
time like the girls give me like I see
the girls about with them the girls give
me his picture you know I mean you can
look at it like it's a bar people are
out having a good time you know it's it
is what it is but for me and my work I
literally like hunt these people and not
like hunt them to do anything bad but
just to know who is who like who are the
traffickers who are the girls working
[Music]
are you fair like the girls inside yeah
yeah I love this bro yeah absolutely out
under percent um I have no doubt about
it the girls are probably soliciting
right now like hey you want to take me
home you know and then they'll get in a
cab or they'll get in their car and take
off and go home and the cops aren't
they're staying at a distance and I can
understand that as well but it just
seems like there's no authority here
there's prostitution happening over
there I guarantee there's drug dealing
going on over there like all those
things are going on right in front of
them and they're not taking a nap and
active measure
[Music]
James in Cleveland sign that for you
ladies
ladies gone mad mama isn't long 30
minutes I don't wake up to 7:30
[Music]
Oh it'll be hot on Thursday
there's like no clouds supposed to rain
today oh it's gonna be a beautiful day
another day not a doctor
[Music]
like strip clubs and stuff right oh no
they're typically I'll do that kind of
stuff on their days off but or like if
like big it off early or if they just
some companies like they just won't even
care like you they'll be out till like
3:00 the morning have to be up at like
7:00 the next day and
I don't know that kind of stuff it's
ridiculous like magnets like we keep
away from that kind of stuff
[Music]
you start talking to me about a party
that was coming up and they wanted me to
come to the party and I was like maybe I
don't know and one of the guys looked at
me and he's like actually you're gonna
work the party and I knew what he meant
by that and I hadn't done anything like
that in several years and I was like no
I'm not you know I'm I'm not gonna do
that and he said yeah either you're
going to work party or you're going to
bring somebody to work the party this is
one of the things I regret the most in
my life there had been a young girl that
lived in my apartment complex that her
mom was in jail and she looked up to me
and she would always say that she wanted
to become a stripper when she got older
she was on me
sixteen and a half getting ready to
graduate high school I asked her I said
hey there's a party and they need
dancers and do you want to dance I knew
that it would probably be more than
dancing but I remember the biggest thing
in my head was I don't want to work that
party
I remember just feeling like oh my god
I'm doing to her exactly what was done
to me and I hated myself for that I
hated it but God was really looking out
for her that night because all she did
was dance and that's a miracle there's a
really important part of the process of
getting ready for action okay look what
is that music and specific music okay
I call it my hunting music all right I'm
ready
and love it
these days are so long and hard and
sometimes when it comes time to do
outreach or super tired and you just got
a
[Music]
buying drug redbull and find that song
yep
[Music]
there's no sense in entering the
darkness to bring hope when you're like
hauled down in outreach pretty typically
is going into active areas where there
could possibly be victims and people we
want to contact with the message of hope
and so it can be all all types of
outreach to strip clubs
to hotels on the street anywhere really
where there would be vulnerable girls a
lot of times when the girls get home
they have to account for everything on
their body just in case she made contact
with someone law enforcement or whatever
so I don't hand out business cards to
girls I hand out something that could be
playful you know just something any girl
would have um so I got these because
they're just little empowerment like I
like your style
you're funny on the back of it I just
write my phone number I don't write my
name because if a pimp Google is my name
he'll see you know I've had girls call
me and say hey can you call my mom and
like rattle off the phone number to me
and just tell my mom I'm okay click and
I'm like I have no idea who that was but
I called a number and I'm like your
daughter just called it and wants you to
know that she's okay that world whether
you're in the bar scene whatever it is
it's it's just so dark so you know
shining the light in the dark I'm ready
- bless Wendy and I that we may be joy
and just love and have something to
offer to somebody in need ask you to
protect us and just be with us and fill
us with your spirit and I say these
things in Jesus name Amen man
[Music]
this one day I was in the dressing room
and I just started praying and I
remember just cussing at God and not
understanding why
[Music]
I was a good person and I just wanted
the right things and I don't understand
why them and not me in this big huge
battle of just wanting to be free and my
name in the life was brandy and he'd
always introduced me my first shift he
would always say we've got beer we've
got wine and now you're gonna have some
brandy just in that real sleazy strip
club you know stuff and it was nothing
to me but this day when he said that I
was like I'm not brandy okay it bugged
me I wanted I was like I'm I'm windy and
something was different in me and I felt
I literally felt the presence of God I
really did um people can say him as
crazy as they want to say I am but I
feel like when I was in the dressing
room praying that he met me where I was
at and that he he was starting to do a
work in me that was pretty phenomenal
and
I felt like he was there and I couldn't
do what I was doing in front of him it
was like peeing in front of my dad or
something and I got off the stage I was
just like like not even halfway through
the song I just could not get into it I
just couldn't I couldn't
[Music]
so many people think that because I'm a
survivor that this work must get to this
this work empowers me this work lets me
have control of the things that happened
to me and to turn around and use it for
good
[Music]
I was just a normal girl just like any
other girl you would have you know the
girl next door I never dreamed that
anything like this would have ever
happened you know I mean but like it
happens to your daughters to your
friends
[Music]
area one wasn't it no feel past
you just go down that
[Music]
the people that come out here with the
right heart the right mind the right
intentions fit right into the community
and get accepted and then you've got
some people that typically end up
getting taken advantage of that's really
sad makes a bad name for all of us out
here
Oh
you know they talk about the American
dream that's it this is really what it's
done for you if you're willing to you
know make some sacrifices and work hard
you know there's a lot of good things in
house and you can be very successful but
only if you choose to you
[Music]
you